bom dia pessoal ei lá todo o pessoal
aqui quem fala é o dar que sejam muito
bem vindos à margem do meia é muito cedo
ninguém está cuidado aqui em casa eu
aproveitei pra começar a gravar expire
office não gosta que o vídeo ofende com
aranha é estar aqui ó
nesse vídeo de uma meta de 200 mil
leques e acho que nós conseguimos bater
disse muito fácil isso nós batista
engessamento do haiti eu compraria uma
tarântula uma aranha real e foi o caso
já encomendei essa aranha muito tempo
ela convencendo outro país já teve que
esperar cerca de dois meses e pelo que
me disseram uma loja ela acaba em
setembro isso quer dizer que minha mãe
está quase a chegar portanto hoje vou
ligar a loja e sabiam de karen está
imagine só as franquias que vai dar pra
fazer muito por aqui principalmente o
windows porque eu tenho muito medo de
aranhas nem é isso que eu vou fazer os
mesmo que não consiga ter aranha o jogo
não tem escada loja mesmo que não vá
buscar amanhã hoje eu vou tentar fazer
aqui alguma franquia tão absurda e
injusta e já é um maluco é que há é uma
loucura que ok eu vou te fazer alguma
coisa maluca qualquer lugar aqui um bom
d'água antes de tudo
ok tudo bem diz o garçom o nosso carinho
pois doentes muito doente e que só vocês
forem novos aqui no canal subscrevam por
bater muito vídeo partir de agora mesmo
estou muito empolgado fazer novos vídeos
e eu vou começar assim também fazer um
pouco mais do blog pelo menos vou testar
portanto se vocês gostarem comenta
equipes vocês gostam do meu isto é muito
rápido com câmera
aí o incrível está possuída
[Música]
mas não só o estado desse cabelo olha aí
também pudera já havia dito que já nem
isso agora vamos acabar porque ainda é
cedo para eu ligar para a loja portanto
eu vou esperar mais uma hora ou duas que
enquanto os corta o cabelo a aaa a água
demora e robertinho é só o melhor
campeonato de portugal e que o som é
muito bom olha aqui o pessoal todo
animado a explicar o que vai fazer
este é o nosso primeiro ano aqui fazer
uma missão impossível né e vamos ajustar
a imagem nessa fé e no que você claro e
rafael famoso e aí nós vamos dar aquele
corte aplicando o conceito do visagismo
tam manterá sua imagem que você já está
usando aí como identidade visual porque
isto é só concluirá o pessoal está uma
pessoa que cuidava da imagem que adapta
o penteado à vossa cara vosso rosto voz
e personalidade já estou pronto pra
magia acontecer o zarbo mystic da hd
colors iniste que blumenau e collor no
meu cabelo vai ficar com o cabelo
molhado e como 80 frente o flamengo está
em sexto com as práticas
[Música]
bom pessoal está o resultado final olha
só tá muito bom está muito vivo
qualquer pessoa nos campos da casa vocês
nem tem noção de como é bom ter o que
deu pronto meu potter parece mais magra
lei jornal no último sábado quando foi
do brasil
tudo bem que a viagem foi muito difícil
eu estou fazendo café num cafezinho que
vamos lá só querem que eu faça um vídeo
na kubota desafio pra te toca à entidade
hoverboard tomando café
o ato não exclui que isso vai te olha um
capítulo muito rápido
agora 31 vai falar agora vou fazer um
salto arriscado olha só muito bom estava
ansioso
assim mesmo o é exatamente como eu ouvi
uma concha irá do meu cabelo café que já
tem o número agora vamos ligar agora é
muito tarde para falar com frango não
sei se a história tem nos falado sobre a
agulha era só possível em estado é que
está a situação porque disse que ela ia
chegar em setembro
merece nem sempre o melhor do rock é uma
coisa quando ela chega à loja toca e já
agora vocês têm outras que eu posso ter
então antes dessa não há mesmo nada né
[Música]
é tudo tão estranho pronto também pronto
fica à espera então é isso obriga missa
no fim de semana a brigada vai ser o
plano pessoal basicamente eu vou
arranjar uma caixa ou e pedir ajuda
maluco é que nós vamos sentir uma caixa
com terra e vou colocar algumas pedras
tempo para simular o habitado maranho e
eu vou esperar que todo o pessoal chega
a casa e quando eu chegar em casa eu vou
mostrar aquela caixa como se tivesse uma
aranha freida é lá dentro e quando ele
sobre minha caixa tipo vou tentar os
estados como maranhão é falso assim o
quer só então agora eu preciso de uma
caixa por aranha lá dentro a falsa em ok
vou pedir ajuda já uma cueca caiu não
vou ter a minha música popular que eu
quero fazer é pôr tipo margem é falsa
dentro de uma caixa e história pessoal
do defendido já tenha então ea
precisamos de fazer é não andar junto às
suas bases das formigas cupins ou muito
estranho muito buraco que me ajudem a
mesma estratégia
acho que é suficiente uma pedra aqui
outra ali no canto
acho que o habitual em fez né olha como
ficou meu irmão que sofre muito você
olha o suprimento de uma pessoa
a opel é bom só tem aqui em nossa caixa
próprio e como vocês puderam ver o antes
dá cá em casa portanto agora é só
esperar o resto do pessoal chega e então
vou ter que esperar umas duas horas eu
acho que agora é só escolher aranha que
vemos por aqui para eu tenho essas
aranhas mas acho muito pequenas na
europa mas é bem assim estava trêmula
lei mas nós precisamos de uma maior e
melhor
só aqui este prefeito ela tem quatro
dentes bem louca policial é meu eu vou
mostrar a língua porque odeia era mesmo
muito melhor fugir pela casa toda a
incerteza tanto para lá
não é só dinheiro
deixa eu sinto que eu pensei que ia
brincar não fazer isso ainda é muito
grande
não é possível sair daqui só não é muito
burro
op você não entendeu que ela pode ter
tudo pensado muito acessado por fernando
corta aqui em casa me parece que a terra
contou com 14 na casa
acho que o falso positivo do tamanho da
empresa
mas gostaria já tudo apenas 80 não foi à
toa que o isolado do ppe tema esse que o
tráfego não tinha além do som
só falta uma pessoa ronaldo ronaldo pio
no socopinho não venha hoje então eu não
vou estar disputando só ronaldo cobra
coral que a pessoa não está abrindo a
porta eu não seria capaz que ela saiu e
não só então é isso pessoal nós vamos
ficar aqui com espírito espero que vocês
tenham gostado motoki com uma caixa de
fósforos porque eu vou tocar uma cueca
lei
consegui fazer antes haja sair partiu
vendeu o bigode
então é isso só espero que vocês tenham
gostado aqui deste vídeo já sabem vocês
são novos aqui no canal subscrevam vamos
tentar atingir os 3 milhões de inscritos
muito rápido quer muito isso e única
recompensa depois posso falar e colocar
mais vídeos que é o que eu quero
portanto inscreva se aqui no canal
deixei muito a equipe e agora tem esta
altura a nova versão só se colocarem
aqui embaixo vocês podem ver estes dois
vídeos e ficarem aqui do lado vocês vão
poder subscrever que o canal é gosta
desta outra em ter uma idéia só fiquem
bem até a próxima